[Music]
this thing right here might as well be
the Loch Ness monster with an iPhone 11
or footage of an alien drinking a
milkshake in area 51
it's a highly guarded secret and anyone
who knows about it or has seen it has
been forbidden from admitting that it
exists for months that is of course
until it made its way here to my kitchen
counter and now to you say hello to DJ
eyes latest creation the Robo master s1
[Music]
you all know DJI it's the world's
largest drone maker and perhaps China's
most popular tech company people obsess
over its products with an Apple fanboy
like lust and DJI delivers bringing out
one new drone after another but now DJI
is decided to bring its talents to the
ground with the Robo master s1 it is
built a robot aimed at consumers who
want to drive around really fast and
then shoot each other with pellets and
lasers because if there's one thing the
world really needed it's the violence of
video games brought to real life the
idea for this new robot started here
it's the annual Robo masters competition
the DJI holds in Shenzhen college
engineering students show up for a
couple of weeks and try to destroy each
other with a variety of robots as you
can see that's a lot of fun the big idea
then was to shrink these robots down to
little ones that regular people could
build and then use in their own battle
you know what says inspiration and
creativity live here this poorly-lit
brutalist building in the shenzhen
suburbs that is a DJI research and
development lab several months ago I
came here to get a first-hand look at
prototypes of the Robo master s1 this
fella here is the lead of the design
team who helped bring this device to
life so this is a video transmitter and
here is a camera and also there's a
shooter mechanism then you get the
bullets yeah 90% of them are made of
water and when it's hits things is
smashed and it disappears and on each
robot
the lights here indicates the hit point
when you repeated in here we go what
will end up being destroyed that's the
object of the game is to chase each
other around and hit these plates is
there like a laser yeah and if you
always aim at the center you should be
fine alright let's do it
[Music]
like shoot gun are you really good at
this I used to be nice to me no no I'm a
good driver but not go there
so you've got that control over there
there's a different mode where you can
use your body in this way we allow
people to control the movement of the
robot you can see it's very sensitive
[Music]
because DJI founder Frank lang is a
cruel cruel engineer
you cannot just buy a Robo master s1 and
play with it no you must first assemble
it by hand and learn things along the
way about robotics and coding here's a
group of youngsters DJI turned into its
product testing guinea pigs
that's something it build as a summer
camp this robot is also an educational
tool to teach programming language for
example it can be used as a autonomous
driving car but we don't have building
functionality for this kids have to
learn how to to program them solve to
achieve these functionalities the hope
is that this will teach kids a few
things get them hooked on robotics and
turn into a worldwide sporting
phenomenon of sorts
well hope that in the future robotics
will become a major sport like football
basketball that's our vision for this
product
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my kids would die to play this and boys
daddy made your dream come true six
months after my trip to China I got my
hands on a couple of the finalized units
here's my oldest son Bowie and his
adorable sidekick Tucker who don't yet
know just how bad the DJI instructions
are going to be gentlemen I've assembled
you here today with cookies and milk for
an important project are we gonna we are
gonna build a robot you guys are up for
it we'll get stuck in you're gonna have
to do most of the building
I could yak on about education and
teachable moments but really I just
wanted my kids to build this thing so I
could play with it that is the coolest
tool I've ever seen
[Music]
it ships with this racing mode where you
can use computer vision to spot targets
placed around the house of course what's
more fun the shooting pellet has laser
mode less mess well many people actually
buy the Robo master s1 it's hard to say
the product requires a lot of actual
work to use it's going to be expensive
and it's much more nichy than deejay
eyes usual devices so it's fair to say
the struggle is real for DJI trying to
create a global Robo masters army as we
see how things play out let's just hope
that the kids remember to wear their
safety goggles and that DJI has a good
insurance
[Music]